alright let's say that we have the
function f of X and it's equal to 2x
plus 5 over 4 minus 3x and what we want
to do is figure out what is the inverse
of our function pause this video and try
to figure that out before we work on
that together all right now let's work
on it together and this is a reminder of
what a function and inverse even does if
this is the domain of a function and
that's the set of all values that you
could input into the function for X and
get a valid output and so let's say you
have an X here it's a member of the
domain and if I were to apply the
function to it if I were to input that X
into that function then the function is
going to output a value in the range of
the function and we call that value f of
X now an inverse that goes the other way
if you were to input the f of X value
into the function that's going to take
us back to X so that's exactly what what
f inverse does now how do we actually
figure out the inverse of a function
especially a function that's defined
with a rational expression like this
well the way that I think about it is
let's say that Y is equal to our
function of X or Y is a function of X so
we could say that Y is equal to 2x plus
5 over 4 minus 3x for our inverse the
relationship between x and y is going to
be swapped and so in our inverse it's
going to be true that X is going to be
equal to 2y plus 5 over 4 minus 3y and
then to be able to express this as a
function of x to say that what is Y is a
function of X for our inverse we now
have to solve for y so it's just a
little bit of algebra here so let's see
if we can do that so the first thing
that I would do is multiply both sides
of this equation by 4 minus 3y if we do
that on the left hand side we are going
to get x times each of these terms so
we're
you get 4x minus 3y X and then that's
going to be equal to on the right-hand
side since we multiplied by the
denominator here we're going to be left
with the numerator it's going to be
equal to 2y plus 5 and this could be a
little bit intimidating because we're
seeing it X's and Y's what are we trying
to do remember we're trying to solve for
y so let's gather all the Y terms on one
side and all the non Y terms on the
other side so let's get rid of this 2y
here actually so I could go either way
let's get rid of this 2y here so let's
subtract 2y from both sides and let's
get rid of this 4x from the left-hand
side so let's subtract 4x from both
sides and then what are we going to be
left with on the left-hand side we're
left with minus or negative 5 or
actually it would be this way it would
be negative 3y X minus 2y and you might
say hey where is this going but I'll
show you in a second is equal to those
cancel out and we're going to have 5
minus 4x now once again we are trying to
solve for y so let's factor out a y here
and then we are going to have Y times
negative 3x minus 2 is equal to 5 minus
4x and now this is the homestretch we
can just divide both sides of this
equation by negative 3x minus 2 and
we're going to get Y is equal to 5 minus
4 x over negative 3x minus 2 now another
way that you could express this you
could multiply both the numerator in the
denominator by a negative 1 that won't
change the value and then you would get
you would get in the numerator of 4x
minus 5 and in the denominator you would
get a 3x plus 2 so there you have it our
F inverse as a function of X which we
could say is equal to this Y is equal to
this right over there